la route était droite
sinueuse
parfois dangereuses mais elle est
rouverte
le couloir de la chine peut désormais
être utilisée par ceux qui veulent se
rendre dans le haut-karabagh
deuxième point d'arrêt la ville de
chouchi à une dizaine de kilomètres de
stepanakert c'est ici que se trouve la
zone neutre et c'est ici que tout le
monde se croise la présence des forces
plus du maintien de la paix est la
pierre angulaire du bon fonctionnement
du cessez-le-feu poste numéro 2 à
proximité du village de shoushi situé à
une dizaine de kilomètres de stepanakert
c'est ici que tout se passe c'est ici
que la police aux frontières
azerbaïdjanaise travail avec les forces
de maintien de la paix russes qui se
trouve juste à côté à quelques mètres de
là la frontière azerbaïdjanaise nous ne
pouvons pas les films et kara no man's
land 2 5 km doit être respecté entre les
deux parties c'est ici aussi que les
colonnes de réfugiés arrivent en
direction de stepanakert par bus pour
arriver jusqu à stepanakert il faut
passer plusieurs contrôles et parfois
affronter les stigmates du conflit la
ville est désormais azéri
beaucoup d'éléments le rappelle mais au
moins la paix est revenue sur ce poste
de contrôle
le drapeau de l'azerbaïdjan côtoie celui
de la russie lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ici
les forces russes du maintien de la paix
ont trouvé un terrain totalement
dévastée vous le voyez ici c'est le
monument d'entrée de la ville de chouchi
il est à terre c'est très symbolique
vous voyez c'est très fort et derrière
il y a encore des carcasses de voitures
avec des impacts de balles
en tout cas le commandant de ce poste de
contrôle nous explique que désormais la
paix ici est revenu malgré des mines qui
sont placés tout autour ce couloir est
désormais ouvert pour laisser passer les
réfugiés les réfugiés qui arrivent par
colonne de bus pour rejoindre
stepanakert enfin pour eux ce trajet est
terminée les forces de maintien de la
paix assure la sécurité de tous ceux qui
rentrent dans les territoires du haut
karabagh chaque voiture est fouillé s'il
ya des armes
je voulais qu'on puisqu'on évidemment et
si tout est propre
nous les laissons passer et ces
personnes peuvent librement circuler le
long du corridor de latchine entier
qu'elle est aux red wings car nos
colonnes les réfugiés qui sont acheminés
en bus depuis la ville de gori sa 300
kilomètres de là sont exportés jusqu'à
la place principale de stepanakert c'est
là qu'ils pourront enfin souffler et
regagner leurs foyers qu'ils ont dû fuir
pendant plusieurs mois
ce monument juste derrière moi est le
symbole de la ville de stepanakert qui
se trouve juste à l'entrée de la ville
et c'est pas cette route que sont en
train d'arriver les colonnes de bus de
réfugiés qui sont escortés par la police
arménienne et par les forces russes du
maintien de la pêche jusqu'à la place
principale de la ville à quelques
kilomètres de là après plusieurs
semaines voire parfois plusieurs mois
d'exil les réfugiés peuvent enfin
retrouver leur maison à stepanakert pour
certains il va falloir tout recommencer
à zéro et entre doute pour l'avenir et
le bonheur la frontière est parfois
mince
nous sommes enfin rentrer chez nous on
ne sait encore ce qu'on va faire
qui vivra verra évidemment nous avons
peur après tout ce que nous avons vu
honnêtement je ne pense pas que tout le
monde rentrera la nouvelle génération
les jeunes vous régler leurs problèmes à
leur façon différemment de nous il y à
des anecdotes nous l'ancienne génération
avons toujours vécu avec l'idée d'une
grande armée soviétique braves est forte
si dieu le veut les choses s'arrangeront
mais qui sait combien de temps cela va
prendre
nous sommes arrivés sans problème tout
s'est bien passé on est parti à 8 heures
du matin et nous voilà arrivés
honnêtement je ne sais pas comment je
vois l'avenir j'espère que les forces
russes de maintien de la paix nous
aideront à nous remettre sur pied
bien sûr que je suis contente s'il
n'avait pas été là nous n'aurions jamais
pu revenir chez nous comment faire sans
eux il n'y a que grâce à eux que nous
pouvons nous sentir en sécurité
je pense que tout le monde va rentrer
oui quelques heures d'électricité par
jour des magasins qui commencent à
rouvrir la vie reprend à c'était pas la
guerre
ah bon